Made this for Prue.
I just need to find my favourite
dish to serve it on.
Noel? Sandi? Yeah, I'm in here.
Noel? Sandi? In here!
Do you sleep in the cutlery drawer?
Don't be silly!
I sleep on a washing-up sponge.
I use the cutlery drawer to
do my diary.
Shall we start the show? OK.
BOTH: Welcome to The Great British
Bake Off!
You haven't seen my favourite dish,
have you?
Oh, I'm really sorry -
it ran away with the spoon.
Oh!
Wow, that's dark!
Last time...
This is the weirdest thing I've
ever done. ..in Festival Week...
Burning, burning, burning. What?
..the Signature Bake
saw a double handshake...
Well done. Well done, Steph.
Shut up!
..but it was Henry's grilled
layer cake which stacked up...
Yes! Well, I think
that's really clever.
..and earned him
his first Star Baker.
And Michael... Claggy, very
stodgy in the mouth. OK.
..became the eighth
to leave the tent.
It's OK, it's OK.
This time, it's
the quarterfinals... Oh!
..and Pastry Week...
If you don't get good lamination,
you're screwed.
..with a Signature Bake...
I don't know whether to tip
it all out and go again.
..which turns everything
on its head...
Really soggy.
..a mystifying Moroccan Technical...
You can't be putting wallpaper
paste on a plate.
Oh, no!
..and a towering Showstopper...
This is so stressful!
..where it's not just the pies...
I can't get it to hold.
..teetering on the brink.
Can it all crash down?
I don't know what to do.
Me neither.
Quarterfinals!
What?!
Pastry Week.
There's going to be
a bit of muddling through.
I'm really not
a pastry person at all.
I've got really warm hands, which
is really nice for health care,
not so good for pastry.
It doesn't like to be handled,
it doesn't like to be warm,
it's not really
a pleasant thing to deal with.
I just don't like pastry.
Morning, bakers.
Welcome back to Pastry Week
and your Signature Challenge.
Today, the judges would like
you to make a tarte tatin.
Your tarte can have
any flavours or toppings,
but it must be savoury
and not sweet.
And it must use full or
a rough puff pastry.
Cos when the going gets tough, the
pastry gets rough or full puff...
I don't really know what I'm saying.
Your tarte must
have good lamination,
which is a Beach Boys song.
And be perfectly baked.
You have two and a half hours.
On your marks... Get set... Bake!
An article I read about
apple tarte tatin said that
the pastry's superfluous.
It's all about the filling.
That will not fly here.
Tarte tatin isn't
something I'd go for.
Um, but if I did, I definitely
would opt for a vegetarian one.
I don't think I've ever
eaten a tarte tatin.
This week, eaten quite a few!
A classic tarte tatin is
made with apples or pears.
You put the pastry
on the top of the frying pan
and then you turn
the whole thing out.
What they've got to do
is create a savoury filling.
They can use cheese,
they can use onions,
they can use mushrooms,
they can use whatever they wish.
Oh, yes!
But if they add too much liquid
to the tarte tatin, it will
soak down and really give
it a soggy bottom.
The key to a perfect tarte tatin -
savoury or sweet -
is the caramelisation.
You need that pie to look
golden and delicious.
I want to see a light, flaky,
golden brown pastry.
The weather is quite warm today,
so utilising the freezer today
I think is going to be critical to
get the good lamination in there.
# Good lamination! #
The bakers could choose to make
either rough or full puff pastry.
But all of them have gone for rough.
If there was time, I'd do full puff.
I mean, I could try and do it,
but it wouldn't go as well. You
know, that's just not a clever move.
Rosie's filling her tarte tatin
with shallots and aubergines
and using black garlic
to add extra flavour
and colour to her
rough puff creation.
What's full puff?
Full puff is when you've
got a slab of butter that you
bash out with a rolling pin. OK.
Stick it in the middle,
fold it in, roll, fold,
roll, fold, roll, fold, roll.
And what's rough puff?
Um, rough puff, you kind of
rub it so it's in smears. OK.
And then keep rolling it
or grating butter in between
the layers. It's quicker.
This is a minute
I'll never get back. Bye.
Today is a rough puff pastry
cos it's hot in here,
and working with a big old sheet
of butter was too risky.
This is the frozen butter
that I've grated,
and then folds create
the lamination.
Without those delicate
layers of butter and dough,
instead of light and flaky, their
pastry will be flat and claggy.
It's all about the lamination today.
If you don't get good lamination,
you're screwed.
HE LAUGHS
With their pastry in the freezer,
the bakers can turn
their attention to fillings.
I mean, look at the size
of this thing!
Hi, Henry. Hello, Henry.
Hello. Right, tarte tatin.
I am doing a crab, new potato
and tomato tarte tatin.
Oh, nice!
Good lord! Good choice.
That's a good reaction.
Henry's topping his tomato
and potato tarte tatin with
a seafood salad, and it's not
just his crab which is well dressed.
Can we talk about your
tie at this point?
Would you like to? You do know
we're in for a heatwave, Henry?
It's quite hot.
But you can always loosen
it off maybe. Yeah.
I could.
I may not.
Good luck, Henry.
Thank you very much.
It's really hot!
Steph's taking a more dressed-down
approach to flavours.
I think cheese and onion go well
together and it's classic.
And I tried putting
tomatoes in there as well,
and it just didn't work.
So I've stuck to my guns.
For her pared-back filling,
Steph's gone for the tried
and tested combination of
shallots and goat's cheese.
Well, it sounds very simple, but
it could be absolutely delicious.
I love goat's cheese. You're
not mad about goat's cheese?
Oh, dear, that's a shame.
I'm not over the moon with goat's
cheese, but it's OK. It's not bad.
Is that what you wanted to hear?
Oh...
I'm starting on the right foot,
aren't I?
In her bid to impress the judges,
Alice is going all-out on design.
So what I'm doing is I'm
creating like a lattice of leeks
on the base of my pan so that,
when you flip it over,
you should get that nice
like crisscross pattern.
Under her woven leeks, Alice is
also incorporating goat's cheese
and a nod to
the origins of tarte tatin.
This is a Granny Smith apple.
It generally tends to
not disintegrate as much.
I just don't want it to be soggy.
That would be the worst thing.
They'll be on it
if it's not perfect.
I'm doing a caramelly, carroty tarte
and then some walnuts to give
a little bit of a crunch as well.
In Bulgaria, we just go to
the hills and you just pick them.
And these ones were actually
picked by my partner's grandma,
so she went up into the hills
and picked these ones.
His nuts may be a treasured gift,
but one of David's ingredients would
normally be thrown in the bin.
Carrot tops?
So I'm keeping
the pie reasonably dry
so that the pastry stays
nice and crisp.
I'm doing a carrot top pesto,
so I use the tops as well.
And then I'm also making
a whipped sirene, which is
a Bulgarian cheese which is
very similar to feta.
Did you bring it from Bulgaria?
I've never seen that in England.
I did have to try and find it
from a shop yesterday in London.
I couldn't order it online.
All these ingredients sound
delicious. Whether they'll be
delicious all together, we will see.
Yeah. Thank you.
So heavy!
Oh!
So this is the second roll,
and then one more after this.
Rectangle, fold,
like a little parcel,
and that helps create the layers.
I'm not an expert at this.
Don't tell Paul!
Look at that!
Tarte tatin fillings
should melt in the mouth.
But retaining the moistness
whilst preventing soggy pastry
is a fine balance.
So they're just roasted,
just till they're soft.
If you want your pastry to be crisp,
you actually want the filling
to be as cold as possible.
So I'm doing everything separately
and then building it in this
while it's cold.
In practice, it's always been
a bit soggy, my tarte tatin,
so I'm just going to fry
a few potatoes so they crisp,
and they will hopefully
act as a sort of barrier.
No-one wants a soggy tart.
No-one!
Lobster arm wrestling.
Oh! Oh, wow.
Oh, you've broken me!
Now practise, lobster.
Oh! Too weak to do the time call?
Yeah, you're going
to have to do it. OK.
Bakers, you are halfway through,
halfway through!
The bakers will only achieve
an attractive golden brown top
to their tarte tatin
if they can marry a well-made
caramel with an appealing design.
So it's just butter and honey.
This should help the leeks
kind of go nice and caramelly.
Over, under, over, under.
Weaving my leeks.
This is what I do, you know.
Right, the construction begins.
I've got ten minutes to do this in.
So I've got a caramel
with ginger, lemon zest
and sumac, then the carrots.
The judges will see what's
underneath, so hopefully they'll
just basically see the carrots.
So I'm going to caramelise
the vegetables in there,
and then the pastry goes on top
of that and it goes in the oven,
so the pattern I'm putting them
in now is the end pattern.
These leeks have gone...
they have gone very soft.
This could all go wrong and I've got
only myself to blame if it does.
It's like there's too much butter
in it. I think I might have put
too much butter in it.
I don't know whether to tip it
all out and go again or whether...
I don't know.
I don't really want to do that.
I think we've got to a point where
I'm happy with the caramelisation.
Fried potatoes over
the top of the tomatoes,
just so there's a bit of a barrier.
I'm just trying to remove
some of the extra liquid
in a totally normal manner that I
was hoping no-one was going to see!
Paul came over and was like,
"Hm, don't like goat's cheese."
I was like, "Oh, good. I'll be
using that." Oh, OK, good start.
And I'm guessing you're
using goat's cheese?
And then it's simple.
Ah, but, you see,
so there's a Danish word - enkelt -
and it means beautiful through
simplicity. Exactly. Simple is fine.
I'm quite simple myself.
I don't like to say. Not as simple
as Noel, if I'm completely honest
with you. Well, yeah, exactly.
I mean, that's like taking simple
to a whole new level, isn't it?
Salvador Dali mobile phone's
not working out.
Bakers, you've got 45 minutes left.
I need to put it
in the oven right now.
It's like a pizza.
Black garlic is sweet and...
It's really good.
But it does mean that the whole
thing is dark so, when they come
over and go, looks a bit burnt,
I'll say it's black garlic!
Now I'm rolling it out,
just to be like my final roll.
It should take between
half an hour and 40 minutes, but
I need to give myself that leeway.
I don't want to be
kind of like one minute left,
and I'm still trying to flip it out.
It's going on as quickly
as is physically possible.
The longer that it's out here,
it's just melting and not cooking.
OK, it's in, it's in, it's in.
I'm just going to do a couple more,
just to allow some steam to escape.
Need to get it in the oven ASAP.
That'll do.
They won't achieve the tricky
trinity of crisp flaky pastry,
moist filling and golden topping
unless they're spot on with
their temperatures and times.
Oh, dear!
Putting it in for 20 minutes at 180.
And then 20 minutes at 160,
so turning it down.
So it's gone in at 190.
It's going to go to
20 minutes at that,
and then I'm going to drop it
to maybe 180.
There's nothing I can do about it.
Right. Let's put it in for 20
minutes and see what it looks like.
I mean, it's in.
Steph,
it won't be doing anything yet.
This is the pesto
with the carrot tops.
I'm going to whizz
that with olive oil.
I'm going to make the crab salad
for the top, which is really fun
and easy to do.
Alice, what the hell are you doing?
I'm just checking.
My pastry's gone in the oven.
Everyone's worried about soggy
right? What, a soggy bottom?
Soggy middle. Soggy middle.
Yeah. Worse than bottom?
Worse than bottom.
You just don't know if it's done.
You don't know what it's doing.
Until you turn it over,
you just don't know.
You can only see the top layer
of pastry - you don't know
what's happening underneath that.
Are you wearing a wet
tea towel as a scarf?
Right, Mother Teresa.
Bakers, you have five minutes.
SAD TROMBONE
Really?
ALARM BEEPS
About now.
I'm too scared.
I think the pastry could be
a little bit soggy under there.
4 minutes 31.
Waiting is the worst bit.
It's just not cooking.
So I'm going to have to drain.
I don't know if any of
it's going to come off.
It's just super sog.
Right, I'll give it
another three minutes.
This has to be done.
And I need time to get all
this malarkey on top as well.
It's got layers.
I'm going to leave it
a couple of minutes in this
before I turn it out.
I've seen conflicting theories
about this tin leaving time.
Just going to leave it,
like... a minute.
At one and a half, it's coming out.
It's just really soggy.
It's getting the last five seconds.
I'm hoping to see it not collapsed.
And now it's just
coming out whatever.
It's nice and crispy on the top,
but who knows about the bottom?
It's the turning it out
I'm scared about.
Bakers, you have one minute -
just one minute.
Um...
It's not horrific.
It is what it is.
Yes, yes, my man!
Hot damn!
Yay!
It didn't stick!
Ta-da!
Bakers! Your time is up.
OK.
That doesn't look too soggy.
Please place your bakes...
At the end of your work stations.
Benches.
There's sog, but little can
be done about that now.
The bakers' savoury tarte tatins
will now face the judgment
of Prue and Paul.
Hello, Henry. Hello.
I actually like the crab on it.
I think it's very original.
I never thought of that.
The sides look OK.
The layers look pretty good.
I'd like to have seen more
caramelisation on the potatoes.
I can't turn this over,
unfortunately.
There's so much on it. It'll fall.
Let me turn over one of these.
Nice pastry.
Nice colour underneath.
It's got a nice lamination, you can
see the pastry very well. Mm-hm.
Your flavours are delicious.
Oh, thank God.
A little hint of, is that chilli
in there? What have you got?
There's a bit of chilli, dill
in the crab. Bit of lemon juice.
Beautiful.
If somebody had said to me,
"This is what Henry's going to do",
I'd have said, "Tell him not to",
but I would've been wrong.
I would've been wrong,
cos it's delicious.
Thank you very much, yeah, it is,
it tastes great, thank you.
Well done, Henry. Thank you.
Cool!
The layers look pretty good.
Yeah, the layers look excellent.
Erm, the burnt bits, though,
probably not as much.
So, these are purple carrots.
Heritage, heritage carrots, yeah.
Oh, they're the carro...
Oh, right OK. Oh.
Just say that now, if anything
gets burnt, just say it's purple.
But it isn't the most attractive
thing to want to eat. Yeah. Right.
It cuts well. It smells great.
You've got a nice, flaky base.
Yeah, and crisp.
Can I have a little bit of that?
Yeah, just a bit,
cos it's quite a dry...
Very dry, actually. It is dry. Yeah.
It needs the sauce,
but it shouldn't be
saved by the sauce, really.
We're judging the tarte tatin. Yeah.
I think your flavours are beautiful,
but it is bone dry.
Thank you.
I'm just going to take a burnt bit.
Not burnt. Not burnt, purple.
Well, I love the lattice.
It's very clever.
I'm a little bit disappointed
it doesn't look caramelised. Yeah.
The layers you can see,
I'm not sure about how
the texture's going to be on this.
Although we did get a nice...
Sounds all right.
..crispy bit there.
Nice.
There's a nice colour underneath.
You've got a little soggy line
running down there.
You can taste the honey,
and it's lovely with the butter.
It is very delicious.
I love the apple, and the,
and the leeks together.
The leeks melt in your mouth.
I just think it's too wet.
I think if you got a little bit
more colour on that... Yeah.
..you would've nailed it. Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you.
Phew!
Erm...
I'm not sure about the goat's cheese
just plonked on top... OK, OK.
..like that.
It looks like an add on, doesn't it?
Yeah.
It cuts well.
Not very thick.
Fairly thin.
Is that for me?
Very nice flavour.
The sweetness from the shallots
really comes through.
The caramelisation is great,
because what you do is
you get this slight toffee.
Goat's cheese does work well with it
but I just would've liked to
have seen it inside. Sorry, yeah.
Yeah.
It is a little bit thin, the pastry,
but I think the flavour,
it can't be argued with.
Thank you. Thanks, darling.
That's lovely.
The flavour comes from a red wine
and balsamic reduction
with black garlic and chilli.
That's where the colour comes from.
I think it's partly
where the colour comes from.
It looks a bit charred. OK.
It's nice and thick.
It's a bit wet underneath here.
There are some layers.
There are layers but...
They are a bit soggy.
..but this here, there.
The big majority of it
is quite wet.
I did make a mistake.
I put in twice the amount of butter
when I was doing my caramel,
so everything was wet at the top.
Right.
Quite a lot of garlic.
I mean, you have to have friends
round who like a lot of garlic.
But that is a very soggy bottom.
Looks like a membrane.
Thank you, Rosie. Thank you. Thanks.
It's never been like that.
There's been a fair bit of
muddling through but, yeah,
that went really quite well.
I didn't expect it
to go that well at all.
Yeah, it was a bit dry.
I mean, the sauces were meant
to make it not so dry.
Paul didn't want to taste those.
But, yeah, that's OK.
Gutted about that.
Dreading the technical, cos, yeah,
another chance
to make more soggy pastry! Yay!
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
The bakers could
practice their tarte tatins,
but they have no idea what they'll
be making in the next challenge.
Right, bakers. Welcome back
to your Technical Challenge.
Always everybody's favourite.
Today it's been set for you by Paul.
Any words of advice?
Consistency really matters
in this challenge.
As opposed to any other challenge.
Right. Is he finished? I think so.
OK, as ever this Technical Challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're going to have to ask
these two gorgeous specimens
to leave the tent. Off you pop.
Where are they off to today?
I think Paul's having a yard sale.
Well, he does have a lot
of old slippers, that's fair.
Anyway, for your Technical Challenge
today, Paul would like you
to make a Moroccan pie,
using warqa or brick pastry.
What?
We have no idea.
Basically, you need to make 12
very thin sheets of warqa pastry,
whatever that may be,
wrapped around a perfectly-spiced
filling to form a pie.
That's all there is to it.
Hey, kids, you've got
two and a half hours.
On your marks. Get set! Bake.
Right.
I've never heard of warqa pastry.
I mean, I'm guessing it's filo-ish.
No, I haven't heard of this!
What is this?
If anyone has heard of this,
I will get naked.
I'm that confident.
I know what this is.
I've seen it on a travel programme.
Moroccan pie, Paul. Yeah.
What is it?
It's a bit like making
filo mince pies. Yeah.
You put layer on layer
on layer on layer
and you build it up,
and you put your filling in,
then you fold over the top.
But it's made with warqa pastry,
or brick pastry,
and this is the difficult part.
The warqa pastry
is quite a loose batter.
It's basically made on a hot plate.
You have to put it on with a brush,
but if it's too thin,
as they're brushing it on,
it'll just disintegrate.
If it's too thick,
it'll act like a pancake,
and just be like splodge. You're not
going to be able to brush it round.
And the mixture is chicken
and obviously a lot of spices.
Yes, but we haven't told them
how much of the spice to use.
The warqa pastry is crispy,
it's delicious,
and it's solid enough to hold
everything together in a slice.
That is so Moroccan. You put it
in your mouth, and it's Marrakech.
Mm. I mean, look how thin it is.
I don't envy them at all.
And there's a heatwave going on.
Would we have given this challenge,
knowing that the weather was
going to be as hot as it was?
You would. Absolutely, yeah.
PRUE LAUGHS
I'm just not going to rush this
cos there's so much stuff
on this sheet of paper.
"For the pastry, mix together
the flour, semolina, salt,
"lemon juice and olive oil,
then add the water."
So you don't want it to be too thick
cos then you're not going to
be able to get such a thin layer.
"Place a flat pan..." ie, that,
"..over a pan of simmering water."
"Paint the batter thinly in circles
"until the whole pan is covered
in a layer of batter."
I don't get it.
I might just try one
and see what happens.
Oh, gosh.
I feel like this isn't right.
What are you doing now?
Explain to me.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
Surely you can't be putting
wallpaper paste
on a plate on top of a pan?
Oh, God, this is grim. I don't know.
What is going on? What is it?
Oh!
I think the first one was quite
thick, actually. Trial and error.
That's the idea, but I obviously
want it to be thicker.
I don't get it.
My pan was too hot,
so I've reduced temperature,
and it's now a little bit easier.
These look a bit better, these.
I don't know why I didn't
do this thicker beforehand,
cos it was clearly
the better thing to do.
I'm not sure I'm doing this right
but something is forming.
Getting there.
It says we need to make 12.
I don't see how it's wrong, like,
I followed the...
SHE EXHALES
No!
This is one of my biggest fears,
not being able to present something!
Steph, no-one can do this. OK.
So don't worry. Thank you.
It looks so difficult.
It's grim.
Keep going.
Just going to take
a different approach.
I'm potentially going to
survive the situation.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Sandi, you need a shave. You're
starting to look like Adam Hills.
Actually, it's a good look for you.
Pretty sexy.
"For the filling, heat
olive oil in a pan,
"and add seasoned diced chicken
and cook through."
I've never cooked chicken before.
This is not how I usually cut my
meat. My meat is usually alive.
So let's get this in.
I'm adding the rest of the meat now.
It's got chilli in it.
Do you think that's too far
gone for a chicken?
Would you be able to get that
chicken back on its feet?
Probably not. No.
"Add the onions and garlic,
the harissa paste, fennel seeds,
"cumin seeds, ginger and cinnamon."
Obviously, they haven't told us
how much to put in.
I've gone for a teaspoon
of everything.
It does smell good.
Well, I don't really like that
much spicy things.
I'm trying to work out
where that heat is coming from.
Oh, and it is the harissa paste.
Ahem.
I don't think it needs any more.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
Want one? I'm fine, thanks.
10, 11, 12.
We're not going to get 12
of these things, wa-warqas.
More batter, more batter.
Looks like a warqa to me.
It's Arabic for "sheet",
and you are making
really sheet pastry.
Yes. Thank you. So crack on.
Right, so,
"Lay one sheet of warqa in the tin
"so the edge sits
in the middle of the tin."
"Continue lining with
the other seven sheets."
Seven?
All of that in there?
I don't think so.
I think that's too much.
So I guess we, we fill the tin.
It doesn't say don't fill the tin.
You can't still be doing that?
The time for that has gone.
It's well past.
You now need to do some business
where you put this in there.
On that. Foldy, foldy.
Goddamn it.
"Fold the overhanging warqa
over the filling, scrunched up,
"so the warqa has some texture."
I think these are too thick. Eurgh.
If they want a bit of texture,
look at that. In the oven.
And I have no idea how long
it's going to go in there for.
It just says "bake."
I'll check it after 20 minutes.
It won't be quicker than that.
Isn't that beautiful?
Not.
I'm now having to get
a bit of a move on.
I think this has just got
to have to do now.
I'm going in, I'm going in,
don't you worry.
No choice.
Oh!
I think I'm going to have to
leave it till the last minute.
The worst case would be,
when I come to shake it out,
it goes "ni".
Ah!
Henry.
Where did he get it from?
A lime tree.
I want to be in on this.
LAUGHTER
Ow!
Has everyone forgotten that we've
actually got to get them out?
Bakers, you've got five minutes,
so stop mucking about.
Let's have a look.
Ugh, I don't know how much
longer that needs.
Well, it's far from baked.
BLEEP
When they say a minute,
it's coming out.
I don't want to drop it.
I don't know if it's right or not.
It's gonna be shocking.
This is really grim.
Oh!
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Come on, boy.
Oh.
If I can't get this out in seconds,
kill me.
Wah!
Come on!
BLEEP
Absolute carnage.
I don't want to get it out the tin.
Oh, my God.
It is leaking juice everywhere.
Oh, dear.
Oh, bugger!
Bakers, your time is up!
Please place your Moroccan pies
behind your photographs.
Paul and Prue are looking
for Moroccan pies
with a well-cooked,
perfectly-spiced filling
and crisp, un-split warqa pastry.
Let's start with this one.
This one...
..there's been issues.
It's a little bit misshapen.
Well, it's burst, isn't it? Yeah.
I think that was probably on there,
and it's been put down there!
Yeah! If I'm guessing.
I think you're probably right.
I can't see any base there, at all.
It's just filling.
It's quite sharp on the spices
but I quite like that.
Yes, it's got good flavour.
Very nice.
But it does look a bit of a mess.
It does.
Er, moving on to number two.
Again, it's broken up a lot.
They've struggled with the
warqa dough in the first place.
Wow. That's difficult to cut.
There is a base to it, though. Mm.
The pastry's a bit thick,
and therefore a bit tough
and undercooked.
I like the filling, though. Mm.
Filling's delicious.
Filling's very good.
This one has struggled with
the consistency of the warqa pasty.
Hmm, yeah. The whole thing's
just collapsed. Mm.
Lovely and crisp.
There is definitely a base on there.
Quite mild flavoured. Mm. Mm.
OK. This is much neater, this one.
It is neater. It's pretty solid.
But I'm really impressed
with the top,
you've got a nice, folded look.
Yeah, it's quite soggy when you get
down to the bottom layer, isn't it?
There's a lot of garlic.
Spicy as well, isn't it?
Hmm, I think
there's too much garlic.
OK, moving on to the last one,
great colour.
It's crispy.
Nice.
Good base on it, as well.
That it is holding so well together,
when it's really very hot...
Yeah, yeah, it is.
..is excellent.
Oh, that's lovely.
Prue and Paul will now rank the
Moroccan pies from worst to best.
OK, in fifth position was...
..this one. Whose is this?
I'm afraid that's me.
Henry, you struggled a little bit
with the warqa pastry.
More colour would've been better.
In fourth place, we have this one.
The filling tasted absolutely
delicious, but it needed longer.
In third position is this one.
Whose is this?
Not bad.
The whole thing came together
quite nicely,
and you do have some
strong flavours in there.
Did you go slightly overboard
with a few? Garlic, maybe?
Maybe, yeah.
I think Prue picked up on.
And then, in second place,
we had this one. Whose, is it?
Mine. Rosie.
And there was some debate about it,
because it exploded,
but you know Rosie, your pastry was
so excellent, and so flavoursome,
and the filling tasted so good,
we thought it should be second.
Thank you.
Which means, first place...
Yes, finally!
All round, it was pretty good.
I mean, you had some
really thin pastry,
but you managed to layer it up
so you couldn't see.
It was solid, it had a strong colour
and the flavours were good.
Well done.
Finally! Well done.
Finally got first place.
Just eight tries.
I don't know how
I got away with that.
My pie exploded!
But, yeah, awesome.
I'm just relieved
to have got through that one.
I was a bit flaky, wasn't I?
Silly me.
At the moment, I feel a bit
like Jesus did on, sort of,
Maundy Thursday.
Awaiting crucifixion.
The bakers have one last chance
to impress
in the showstopper challenge
before Paul and Prue
decide who is star baker
and who must leave the tent.
I do not know where we are.
Henry, brilliant signature,
lousy technical.
David, you thought it looked
like he'd burnt the carrots
but then he came first
in the technical. I know.
We're in the same situation
as we have been for the last
couple of weeks, where they've
literally just reversed
so it all relies
on the showstopper again.
Alice may be in a little
bit of trouble, uh, Rosie,
possibly Henry's in a little
bit of trouble as well.
I have to say his signature,
my lunch was delicious.
I mean, who would've thought?
You're just here for the free lunch.
Who would've thought of putting
crab on top of a tarte tatin?
You guys, your eyes lit up
when he said that.
Rosie, I keep thinking
she's in trouble
and then she manages to
kind of get herself back.
I have no idea, at the moment,
who's winning, frankly.
It, it's so tight, uh,
they've got to create a little
bit of Bake Off magic.
Semi-final week next week.
Well, their nerves may well
come into play today.
Morning, bakers.
Welcome to your
showstopper challenge.
Today Paul and Prue would like you
to make a stunning vertical pie.
Vertical pie? Crazy!
What's next, a horizontal quiche?
I think all quiches are horizontal.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Good point.
Move on, shall we?
Uh, Paul and Prue would like you
to make a large pie base with
decoratively shaped pastry arranged
vertically supporting at least
two further pies.
Your fillings can be
savoury or sweet
and you can use any pastry you like.
Yeah, but not each other's. No. No.
You've got four hours.
On your marks... Get set.
..bake!
I'm just gonna make loads of pastry
and get it chilling in the fridge.
Pie's not at all my thing, like,
don't know why I've never had
a massive penchant for a pie.
I think everyone's feeling
the pressure
of this showstopper particularly.
This is a fairly crazy idea.
It's a vertical pie.
What we mean by that is they have
to make minimum of three pies
stacked on top of each other.
They can be just boringly stacked
but I'm hoping they'll be
more interesting than that.
Whether it's shortcrust
or hot water crust,
the choice of pastry is critical.
The pastry needs to be
thin enough to be delicious
and firm enough to hold
the whole thing together.
The flavours have
gotta be there as well.
Too much liquid in their filling
can seep down.
You want to be able to put the knife
through and cut a wedge out
and let it all hold its shape.
This challenge has to be difficult.
We're looking for the four best
people to go into the semi-final.
Morning.
Morning, Alice.
Alice, tell us all about
your vertical pie.
So I'm making a, a tree trunk
out of pastry which is gonna support
a pie on top and then
the tree house made of pie
and a swing hopefully that can...
Perfect.
Kind of swing in the breeze so...
Wow.
Alice's swing, three apple and
blackberry pies and the hollow
tree trunk supporting them
will all be made
from crumbly shortcrust pastry.
You have shortcrust which is gonna
have to be quite thick
to support a pie.
Yeah, so it's quite heavy
and I hope, I really hope that it,
it kind of stays, yeah.
Sounds like I could live in it,
do you not think?
I'm a little bit nervous.
Well, yeah.
You could live in it.
Well, with a ladder.
Oh, no, I'm making a ladder.
There is a ladder.
You are, there you go.
Oh, perfect.
Pastry ladder.
Ladders aren't the only things
being scaled in the tent today.
I'm doing, a fish pie.
My theme is based on Whitby, the
town that I come from
cos that's a fishing port
but also it's an old whaling town.
His nautical showstopper may be
full to its shortcrust brim
with fishy flavours but there's
one traditional feature of a pie
David is throwing overboard.
Is there a reason why you haven't
got a lid on any of your pies?
No... no, I do.
I really like cos it's all...
What makes a pie a pie?
Well, true actually because a pie
is the lid, isn't it
because normally in the past
you've had a... It can be.
A tin, a tin with a lid on top.
It can be.
And a tart would be underneath.
It's an open pie?
Yeah, it is an open pie, yeah.
If they overwork their shortcrust
or don't rest it for long enough
in the fridge,
it can become tough and rubbery.
So basically I want these chilling
so that I can make my filling.
All the other bakers are using
hot water crust pastry
which they'll prepare later as it
needs to be shaped while warm.
In the meantime,
they've started on their fillings.
So this is just some
chopped chillis.
These are all going into the curry.
I think when I was, like, really
young, the first thing I ate was,
well, maybe not the first thing,
but I was a bit of a curry girl
when I was younger so, uh, goes back
to my childhood a little bit.
Steph's also revisiting childhood
with her design, a three-tier
fairground carousel complete with
delicately painted pastry horses.
I just saw somebody get married and
have a carousel at their wedding.
Oh, that's very cool.
I know it's a good shout, isn't it?
That's very,
almost worth getting married for.
Well, exactly. Not quite.
I mean, no. No.
Steph's not the only baker hoping
to curry favour with the judges.
This is for the,
the curried vegetables.
Mild really.
I think my, my husband doesn't eat
anything spicy at all.
I'm, I'm slowly,
slowly converting him.
I put a little bit more
chilli in everything I do.
Even Rosie's husband, Lewis,
has approved the spicy vegetable
filling for her pie tower.
Her tree, birds nest pies
and a camembert dragon will complete
her ambitious fairytale design.
Rosie, how many pies altogether?
Nine pies.
Nine pies?
Nine pies? Wow. Yes.
Are you gonna finish this on time?
Yes.
Have you practiced this?
Have you done all of it?
Uh, yes.
Ish!
Henry. Hello.
Hello, hello.
Morning.
This is obviously
a savoury pie, then?
This, this is
pretty savoury, this bit.
Did you just steal some ham?
Oh, yeah. Do you want
some ham? I've got so much.
Yes, I'd like a piece of ham.
Stop this, Paul.
Here, here.
Uh, stop it you lot.
Henry, Henry, hey, stop it, you two.
Yes, my darling. Yes.
Henry, could you explain
your vertical pie to us?
Yes, so I'm doing a sweet
and a savoury. Oh.
It's gonna look like a chandelier
hopefully.
Or reminiscent of a chandelier.
Henry's upside-down chandelier
will consist of four pies.
Two chicken, ham and chorizo
and two spiced chocolate and pecan.
So what's the, connection between
the sweet and the savoury pies?
They're just really nice flavours.
With the cinnamon...
Who, who says?
My mother's palette.
Don't you dare.
I won't mess with your mother.
No, no, no, that's fine.
So, good luck then.
Thank you, Henry.
Sweet or savoury,
the judges will be expecting
moist fillings packed with flavour.
The granny smith are quite sharp
but you've got the caramel which
makes it really nice and sweet
so should all balance really nicely.
That looks fabulous, darling.
It is incredible.
Is it from Whitby?
No, but it could be.
Was it fun growing up there?
Did you go, "Yay?"
It was fun when you were really
young and then as a teenager
you obviously had the thing of like,
"We're in the middle of nowhere."
There weren't quite the clubs
that you were looking for?
No, definitely not the ones
I was looking for.
OK, fair enough.
I've got 15 minutes to get these
pies in the oven
and that's actually doable.
Do you like meaty pies?
Or can you go overboard,
do you think?
It's the eyes, it's the eyes.
It's like a shark
but with even less mercy.
Even if they think their fillings
are in hand, Steph, Rosie
and Henry still have their pastry
to worry about.
There's lard and the butter.
That's so much fat.
Hot water crust's a dough
you can knead a lot more
than standard pastry.
As it cools down, it goes like
really brittle and you can't use it
so you have to use it pretty
much straight away.
Whatever their pastry,
if it's too thick, the bakers risk
an uneven bake and raw dough.
Too thin and it may be too weak
to support their structures.
It's all about balancing
the structural integrity of the pie.
Gotta hope that it all
kind of holds together.
I am really nervous actually.
I think I've caught the sun a bit.
You are a tiny bit red.
Hmm.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Halfway through.
Ooh, I'm worried about timings now.
This is the base pie.
Probably a bit behind
so a bit flustered by that.
In all the recipes I've read, it
says to put this piping nozzle
in the top but this piping nozzle's
going directly into meat filling.
So I don't know how the steam
goes through but I'm doing it.
With multiple pies of different
shapes and sizes, achieving
the perfect bake will test
the bakers' skill and stamina.
I'm doing so much.
I always do so much.
So it's going in for
an hour and ten.
Two in the oven.
Many to go.
Right, I just need to
get my last pie in the oven.
Ooh.
You're doing dragons, aren't you?
One dragon. One dragon.
Just, just the one.
Just one. Got a name?
Yeah.
He's called Bert.
Camembert Bert?
Yeah.
Bert, the dragon?
Unicorns, rainbows.
Yeah. He made a few faces but...
Paul's all over that stuff.
Why don't any of you just
do a sports car?
What's wrong with you?
This is for the pecan pie filling.
I'm going to get the filling ready,
do the decorations.
I can do that in an hour
and a half, if I work fast.
Bakers, important Noel announcement.
You have one hour remaining.
I thought we had like
two hours left.
That is not enough, the...
Oh, iIt's so not enough time
for this.
Pie marathon, that is.
Pie, pie, pie, pie, pie, pie, pie.
Right, they're in.
And if perfect pies
weren't tricky enough,
they also need to craft
exquisite pastry decorations.
So these are the horses.
I'm making a tree.
It is a fairytale tree.
So I'm making a tree trunk
for my tree house.
Think I'm a little bit mad.
I realised you can make scales
by using the cutter.
These are the shapes
which are going round the edge.
The thing about chandeliers is,
you can have them
as minimal or as ornate
as you'd like.
So we'll see how ornate
this one gets.
Oh!
That's the rest of Bert.
OK, Sandi, what I'm gonna do is,
I'm gonna throw the sack in the air,
you dive out of it,
do a forward roll in mid-air
and say, "Bakers, you've
got half an hour left"
OK? Right, perfect.
One, two, three.
Bakers,
you've got half an hour left.
Useless!
I think I need to get my pie
out of the oven.
The pies need five more minutes
but I can't really give them
that five more minutes.
Those actually look OK.
I'm actually fairly happy.
We have no idea
but we'll call it done.
Happy enough with that.
Can you hold the glass?
The glass? Yeah, I've got the glass.
It will come off,
there's just something...
I don't know what to do.
Me neither.
So that's worked.
Right.
Definitely lost the portholes.
I just freaked out then. Ha!
Important Sandi announcement.
Bakers, you have ten minutes.
I always want an hour
to assemble at the end
and I always have ten minutes.
Whoo!
There we go.
This is gonna act as a little stand.
These waves are strong enough
to hold it up.
A dragon with a head.
This is so stressful now.
So they're to just support the pies.
No dowels no, not for any reason
other than the fact that
I'm stupid, I think.
It's the pie of shame.
Boat, boat there, done.
Right, I mean, I just need
a few minutes to decorate it.
Bakers, you have one minute.
Just one minute.
I've made a little swing.
Can literally all crash down
but what can you do?
I can't get it to hold.
Oh. Oh, for God's sake.
Right bakers, that is
the end of the challenge.
Ta da.
That was terrifying.
Not perfect, but OK.
Oh.
Come on!
The whole pie's falling apart.
I'm going home.
NOEL: Prue and Paul will now judge
the bakers' vertical pies.
SANDI: Rosie, please bring
up your vertical pie.
Shall I come and help you?
Yes, please.
This could go badly wrong. NOEL: Oh.
It's like a strange game.
No rush. NOEL: Oh, my God.
SANDI: Hang on a minute.
Right which way? Here?
I think the design's amazing.
The knight down here,
it's been blasted. Um...
SANDI AND PRUE LAUGH
It's just lovely. It's imaginative.
Thank you. It's very
funny too, which I love.
It's like a nasty giant
attacking a castle.
The pastry's too thick
for the size of that.
Yeah. It should be much thinner.
The curry flavour is good
but your filling is very dry.
It's very bitty.
It just falls apart.
I was just so scared of
the moisture. Yeah. Yeah.
I was just so scared of it.
But it can be your enemy as well.
The dryness is... I know.
..probably worse. OK.
I want to have a quick look
in the dragon, if you don't mind.
Yeah, he's a different filling.
Argh. Oh, bye-bye, bird.
SANDI: Saint George.
It's very dry too.
I think the idea, the sculpture
of it is excellent.
I think the textures are all wrong.
OK.
Thanks, Rosie. Thank you, Rosie.
The trunk of the tree,
it's very well done.
I think the overall design
with the swing as well,
it's exceptional.
The pastry's tough as old boots.
You've just worked it too much.
I would not say it was
tough as old boots,
but it isn't the tenderest
pastry we've ever had.
And the filling's quite dry.
You've taken too much
moisture out of it. Yeah.
I very seldom say this,
but I would say there isn't quite
enough sweetness in the filling.
The idea is fantastic but, for me,
it's not quite there.
Thank you, Alice. OK, thank you.
Very imaginative.
It's wonderfully intricate
and really interesting
and it's obviously
a big marine story.
You've got that whole idea of
three pies being one story.
I think the design is very good,
the way it's been constructed.
The exposed veg...
..I don't really like.
It needs to be more of a lattice
thing to enclose it, for me.
The pastry could've been baked
a little longer underneath.
Hmm.
Pastry's lovely and short.
I think your filing in there's
slightly over seasoned.
I agree, it's a bit too salty. Hmm.
It's the smoked salmon of course.
And it feels quite dry.
You lost all the moisture when
you... because it's... it's got no lid
so it just blew away.
Well, I love it.
The little horses are lovely,
the pastry is properly browned.
The little pastry squares could've
been thinner... Mm-hmm, yeah.
..and then put on the side.
They're a little bit clumsy.
OK. But it is neat
and it's very organised.
It's very Steph.
It's holding together nicely.
Delicious, Steph.
It's not too dry,
curry flavours are lovely.
To get a wall like that,
a filing that's not moving
and still carry the moisture and the
spices, it's really, really good.
The pastry is nice and thin.
And nice and thin. Yeah, it's flaky.
That's a really nice pie.
Oh, thanks. Thank you, Steph.
Well done. Thank you.
ROSIE: Well done.
Henry, would you like to bring
up your vertical pie? Yes.
Uh, ooh.
This is terrifying.
Ooh, sh...
ALL LAUGH
Right.
Well, my first feeling is
basically you've stacked one
pie on top of another... Hmm.
..which is a bit unimaginative.
Putting dried leaves on top of
a pie is never a good idea.
It just doesn't look good.
But let's have a look at
one of the pies, shall we?
SANDI: What's that face?
What am I going to say, Henry?
I think you're going to say
my pastry's a little thick.
A little thick? It's a lot thick.
OK.
So much so that you've got
rawness in there as well.
You needed that paper-thin.
It is very dry.
If you'd used a fattier meat you'd
have got... OK. ..a better result.
It's bone dry.
And what's happened is
all the moisture's come out
the hole at the top. It's a shame.
That's quite thick
as well, isn't it?
Do you know what it
tastes like? Mince pie.
You're not getting
a lot of chocolate.
You're not getting the pecan.
I'm getting more Christmas
flavours coming through.
Do you like Christmas? Humbug.
ALL LAUGH
Um, the idea's there, Henry,
but not executed to
the best of your ability.
Maddening. Thank you. Thank you.
Phew!
Am I in danger? Yeah.
This leaves me inches beneath
the guillotine blade.
ROSIE: I think it's probably
the hardest one to call in
terms of who's going home.
Also one of the hardest points
in the competition to leave so it's
going to be horrific. And,
you know, not going to lie,
if it's me, I'll be gutted.
We didn't try anything,
but it was a visual feast.
Unfortunately that's
where it stopped. Ah.
And it was so disappointing.
That horrible word kept
creeping back in - dry. Dry.
The only one that got it
right was Steph.
She's come from very middle ground
to put herself in line
for Star Baker.
David must be up
there for Star Baker
because he came first
in the technical.
And his design was amazing.
So let's look at who
we're worried about.
The one I was, I suppose,
most disappointed by is Henry.
The dryness and
thickness of the pastry.
It was also disappointing,
was it not, as a design?
Yes, he just stacked a few pies...
Yeah. ..one on top of another
and say it's an upside-down
chandelier and that's the theme.
Even though he did well in his
signature, I think he struggled
with the technical and I think
he's struggled with this as well.
I'm going to imagine
we're worried about Rosie.
You didn't particularly
like her Signature.
No, it didn't look
particularly good.
On the Showstopper
she struggled a little bit.
The design was probably
one of the best there,
but it was very, very dry. The
whole thing just fell to pieces.
Yeah, I think
they're both in trouble.
To come this far, it's a terrible
point in the competition
to go out, isn't it?
Well done, my lovely bakers.
This is the moment we find out who
is going through to the semifinal.
I can tell you that
one person who definitely is,
is the Star Baker of this week
and that person is...
..Steph.
Oh, my God.
That means I've got the horrible,
horrible job of announcing
which baker is going home.
The baker who's leaving us
this week is...
..Henry.
Aw, Henry. Oh, my darling.
I met Paul outside
the Bake Off tent when I was 12.
I remember shaking his hand then.
Unlucky, mate.
And I never thought it would
get to a stage where I was
standing behind one of the
benches in there, actually baking.
I think you struggled a bit today...
Just a bit. ..didn't you? Yeah.
Little bit.
I think he's done a great job
overall and he has improved.
I just think, overall, I think
the other four are better.
It has been a pleasure, darling.
Henry.
Oh, darling, Rosie.
Really, really sad to see Henry go.
Henry is awesome. He's great.
But so happy to still be here,
like...
Well done, Alice. Thank you.
Rosie's still not
believing her luck.
You nailed it.
What? Oh, wow.
Wow, wow, wow. And pastry?
Well done, Steph-Steph.
Steph's Showstopper was faultless.
I could not find a single thing
to complain of.
Is this real?
NOEL: Next time...
Is that right? It can't be right.
I might just start again.
..it's the semifinals...
There is no room for error now.
..and the last four bakers...
Ooh, way too hot.
..face a tarty signature...
They look like very small implants.
..a geometric technical...
Roll into a square.
I don't know what I'm doing.
..and a see-through Showstopper...
If you break it, gone.
..to reach the final...
It has to be just amazing.
Oh, God.
..of The Great British Bake Off.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media